a very Brady renovation what is it like
renovating your childhood TV home well
first of all it wasn't our home it was a
house in Studio City that they used to
represent the Brady Bunch house our real
house was on a set on stage five this is
a wacky crazy idea yeah they're buying
is there buying a picture right right
outside of a house that we all think is
the real house which it wasn't at all
and they invited us to come in and share
memories and lend our ideas and
contribute items and and work with some
of the best talent that HG has to offer
nine of them and we've had a great time
it's been like a reunion and a project
and and and there's a real house that
came out of it yeah and I know they're
renovating the interior of the home Oh
match what you guys saw every day on set
just a little yeah it's it's sort of a
restoration but what they're restoring
didn't exist they had to create it yeah
so it's a it's a recreation that's now
become a restoration and it's it's it's
really remarkable what they pulled off
in a short amount of time you'll see
it's it's wild the detail is amazing and
we were talking fabrics patterns Rock
positioning the Atlantis I mean the
kitchen but in addition to that HG
reached out through the internet looking
for specific items that we couldn't
locate and so fans got involved and they
had the finials that would go on top of
chairs there were just perfect blocks a
refrigerator someone contributed we did
the horse in the living room that was
sort of iconic knit a staircase that's
all been recreated that's some horse oh
that's so cool yes I like I everyone
loves the Bradys it's like you know why
do you think everyone loves the Brady so
much because it's all me it's all her
it's a kinder gentler time it's it's a
it's a feel-good I think I kind of kind
of kind of show with a like moral it's a
it's I think reminiscent of the kind of
television we're not seeing quite as
much up today so for many people it's a
it's it's a recollection is a nostalgic
kind of kind of hit of when they watch
the show up that whatever time in their
lives that they watch the show yeah when
renovating this home do you guys fall
into your old like personas from the
show is there sibling rivalries is there
anything that happens while renovating
that you're like there's anyway
independent of any renovation or any TV
show we all get together and all six of
us have not been together for over 15
years
Wow at the same time yeah I mean we see
each other but not all so that's that's
something that that HGTV really yeah
that's a that's a big deal yeah what was
that your first time see when you guys
all collectively saw that house for the
first time was that your first time
seeing it in real life then it was
always a picture some some people had
been to the house or driven driven in
front of the house but for me I didn't
even know where it was so yes it was and
it of course wasn't anything like our
the house that we turned it into on the
inside yeah so it was really quite a
challenge but HGTV really did it I
literally had been in the house and
didn't know it was the house I just came
out of the car walked in didn't really
take in do you know the outside wasn't
even thinking that way and I was a guest
of the owner and we were sitting around
and they said
I do you notice anything and I didn't
know what they were talking about
because from the living room it doesn't
end well getting like it so we had to go
outside from the street oh wow alright
yeah you should see it now
oh boy oh I'm excited yeah in some sense
she probably has seen it right close to
my house oh I live it's not far
what I mean is that it is exactly like
it looked on TV so you know what it
looks like yeah
obviously we're Canadian we're very
proud of the property brothers whatever
they like working with the tear grains
as well you should be a there we go oh I
feel like we need an a collective so no
they're great Wow they are they're so
smart and funny and interesting and
entertaining and just really
down-to-earth fun guys to work with and
they're really the people that that that
did the work yeah really like you know I
mean they really are the people they do
the work on their on their show yeah we
did it on this one too
oh we're going to get the tea from that
and there's a little help from the
Bradys mmm
we picked up a sledgehammer like how
physical were you guys really getting um
I did demo um I did some crafting I know
Mike did demo Barry did demo and some
rebuilding I like Emma painting
repurposing yeah pulling things up me
yeah shopping what I'm happy yeah you
know the the the screen behind the the
parents bed in the master bedroom okay
there's that japanese-style likes room
divider okay yeah well I built that with
with jasmine wrong
fun fact HG 10 stars so we're excited
they've got it all all from from what it
looked like to the the props the stage
by stage process it is coinciding with
an exciting event in the Brady history
which is the 50th anniversary of the
first airing the first episode September
26 1960
yes so September will be H G renovation
month beginning on the 9th and runs
right through to my birthday what are
the chances someone in this group is
gonna want to buy this house like how
much do you love it would you want to
live in it I wouldn't want to live in it
no thank you yeah yeah I have my own
design ideas I want to be able to come
back when I'm in LA
oh and knock on the door and say hey I'm
Mike looking man how you doing can I
come in
that would be sorry that's as far as I'm
gonna go I'm looking for the adventures
they're going to do with it I know
they're running a contest where a fan
can stay there for a week you know kind
of a friggin I think that HGTV will have
clever ideas with how to use it
integrate it with fans in public and
maybe do some TV shows from there and
keep that keep it alive so that's
exciting for us yeah
so neither of you want to stay the night
pretty small giant king-size bed in my
house I was responsible for four I had
contributing to helping do Greg's attic
bedroom the way out of the bush and so
that that room is rocking I'd be I'd be
cool about that
you